now it is time for our favorite time of
the week it's time to salute our
everyday superheroes with southwest
medical here are two new honorees
congratulations dr neil gokul and jamila
watson
thank you so much salute to superheroes
how does that make you guys
feel jamil i'll let you go first um it
makes me feel overwhelmed with joy
i wasn't expecting this at all just to
be a first year medical assistant so
this is something
i'm very proud to have been nominated
for and even
won i i would never have expected this
this is
a complete honor for me i i heard there
were some tears
when you found out you did maybe
well deserved well deserved dr goku how
do you feel it's incredibly overwhelming
and truly humbling it was just a shock
to see
and and really nice to receive and dr
goff you're always
joining us to give the community
information so let's just talk about you
for a chance for a change
um what's your specialty and and what do
you do
i'm a family medicine physician so i see
children and adults of all ages and i'm
also the medical director of education
so i have the
esteemed privilege of getting to work
with many of our future providers
including medical students pa and aprn
interns as well as our resident
physicians
awesome and jamila how about you i'm
actually a medical assistant for our
pre-visited department
we take care of our medicare medicaid
patients and make sure we do
preventative procedures
and schedule critical appointments for
them so they can stay on top of their
health
wow and jamila what inspired you to do
this what inspired you to go into
the medical field when i actually came
into
the healthcare medical field thinking of
my late parents i wanted to honor them
and move forward in my life knowing that
i was doing something right
and something that they would want me to
do and this sits well with my heart
being able to give back to people and do
my part
wow wow that's beautiful congratulations
i know you're making them so proud
dr gokul how about you i would say very
similarly my family through the
trajectory that
they lived and what i went through with
my sister's health it really empowered
me to want to be part of
delivering health care in a community
that i really care about
and what would you say brings you joy on
your day to day especially now when
being in healthcare is just it's hard
it's tough
jamil you can go first um being able
just to wake up every day and
to give back in the smallest way whether
it's making a patient smile or
helping them schedule an appointment
that they were they were
basically shying away from the
relationships certainly fuel my energy
and my passion
even from behind plexiglass and masks
and still
able to smile and laugh and be around so
many caring and compassionate
individuals
be mindful of your health because health
is wealth that's what's going to keep
you here and keep you thriving and also
to remember that preventative health
care is so
important this year more than ever and
not to avoid going in for those visits
in any type of capacity
love hearing their stories congrats
again dr gokul and jamila thank you so
much
for everything you do every single day
we'll be right back in las vegas